Luis Ignacio rula da Silva y su visa
giraldo alkin nació declarados hoy por
el Tribunal Superior electoral idóneos
para la investidura que se celebrará el
1 de enero en Brasilia ha sido un acto
protocolario en Brasilia en el que hemos
visto a un Lula visiblemente emocionado
que incluso ha llorado recordando su
prisión se ha alegrado de que el pueblo
brasileño haya escogido la democracia y
ha recordado los momentos más difíciles
del último año con los ataques por parte
del Derrotado presidente bolsonaro
contra las urnas electrónicas y las
principales instituciones del país hay
que destacar que había preocupación con
esta ceremonia que incluso se iba a
celebrar el 19 de diciembre y ha sido
adelantado una semana porque desde el
inicio de noviembre los bolsonaristas
siguen acampados delante de los
cuarteles militares en las principales
ciudades de Brasil algunos los más
radicales
amenazaban con imp este acto finalmente
las protestas en Brasilia han sido mucho
menores de lo que se esperaba y la
pregunta ahora es si seguirán acampados
los bolsonaristas y se intentarán
boicotear la investidura el uno de enero
nosotros estaremos allí en Brasilia para
contarlo